Have you ever noticed that the attractive
kids in high school always got better grades
than you?
Yeah well science has found out why!
In a recent study published in the journal
Inside Higher Ed, researchers found that college
professors gave more attractive students better
grades, specifically the ladies.
The study found that women who were rated
as less attractive had slightly lower grades
than their better looking peers.
It’s a small difference, the authors describe
it as “the difference from an A-minus to
a B-plus.”
But interestingly, and perhaps more tellingly,
this “grade punishment” as the researchers
called it, disappeared when the women took
online classes.
The researchers believed it was a mix of professors
investing more time into better looking students
and simply giving better grades to prettier
people.
And these better looking students probably
got the same treatment in high school too
according to a book on the topic.
In an analysis of data from almost 9,000 high
school students, researchers found that yet
again, the prettier students had better grades.
But being the BEST looking didn’t matter
so much as being better looking than average.
Those who weren’t as attractive were more
depressed and had fewer friends, issues that
could affect school performance.
But being hot doesn’t necessarily mean you
get the best grades.
While they did have better grades… they
also got more distracted.
By dating and partying, which of course offset
some of the gains in grades.
It’s just well… society treats you better
if you’re considered hot.
There are tons of studies that support the
fact that pretty people have an edge in society
outside of school as well.
Attractive people are paid more, perceived
to be more intelligent and heck, one study
published in the British Journal of Developmental
Psychology found kids trust attractive people
more!
But, it’s not because hot people are smarter,
better qualified for a job, or more trustworthy.
Instead, it comes back to people's belief
that attractiveness correlates with intelligence.
This is called the Physical Attractiveness
Stereotype.
And this is a worldwide phenomenon.
One study published in the Journal of Cross
Culture Psychology found that Koreans thought
that attractive people were more trustworthy
and concerned for others, values highly prized
in their culture.
But looking good isn’t all it’s cracked
up to be.
A study published in the Journal of Social
Psychology found that if a woman was considered
good-looking she was less likely to get certain
jobs, especially the more traditionally masculine
ones with titles like “manager of research
and development, director of finance, mechanical
engineer and construction supervisor.”
Researchers called this the "beauty is beastly"
effect.
So I guess you should follow that old saying,
“you shouldn’t judge a book by it’s
cover”.
Unless that book is getting better grades
then you for the same exact work, then maybe
you should say something.